today we're talking about cortex
framework automatic capacity
recommendations and application
observability i'm piccola and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
google cloud cortex framework helps you
kickstart time to value to get up and
running quickly with google cloud
we're extending our available content to
include pre-defined bigquery data marts
and looker reporting templates focused
on enabling faster time to insight for
common order to cash and financial
analytics
customers have told us that by having
the various lines of business data
available within bigquery it opens up
new opportunities to extend with other
data sets to gain new insights and
better optimize core business processes
check out our blog for more
bigquery already offers flexible pricing
models such as on-demand and flat rate
pricing for running queries to meet the
diverse needs of our users
we're excited to make it even easier for
you to optimize bigquery usage with new
bigquery slot recommendations powered by
activeassist
it's a part of google cloud's ai ops
solution that uses data intelligence and
machine learning to reduce cloud
complexity and administrative toil
when it operators and architects begin
their journey with google cloud they
zero observability needs tend to focus
on infrastructure and aim to address
questions about resource needs a plan
for scaling and similar considerations
developers and devop engineers also make
a plan for how to get deep observability
into the performance of third-party and
open source applications running on
their compute engine vms
that's why we recently launched a
dedicated ui under monitoring
integrations that guides you to the
available integrations that may be a
good fit for your fleet
automatically installs relevant
dashboards to help you get value faster
and shows you the integrations that are
live on your vms
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see the full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud